We all hear about big demographic
changes underway these days in China, the
world's most populous country: falling
birth rates, rapid population aging, and
shrinking workforce totals, with national
population decline just around the
corner. Yet, the most important population
change in China today maybe one we
seldom hear about, one that Chinese
population controllers almost never
mention. This is the revolution in
Chinese family structure, an astonishing
transformation, a major break with all
past patterns, an unstoppable trend
driving China into completely new,
uncharted social territory. The vanguard
of this revolution is China's new family
type:
only children begotten by only children.
This rising group of young men and women
has no siblings, cousins, uncles, or aunts —
only ancestors, and maybe someday
descendants. Extended family networks
have been the foundation of social and
economic life in China since Chinese
civilization began. But now these
networks are atrophying, and for millions
evaporating altogether. Will China
manage to cope? Or is this a huge
civilization challenging surprise? Stay tuned.
What do you think is China's most
pressing population problem? Let us know
in our poll. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.